MALE PUPPET: I love singing and dancing.
Hiya, folks.
For fifty cents, I'll suck your dick.
Well, it's a great price. It almost makes me wish I had a dick for you to suck.
Oh, I'll take that as a yes.
You two were the most decorated officers in this department, what do you see?
Looks like a robbery gone wrong to me.
This wasn't a robbery, this was a hit!
What the--?
PHILLIPS: Someone out there is killing puppets.
FEMALE PUPPET: Hey, handsome.
Looking for some rotten cotton?
I'm a woman!
That's okay.
Yeah, that's even better!
We've got a good time for you.
PHILLIPS: We're gonna catch the bastards who did these murders. These bodies are gonna start piling up.
You're one of the best damn cops I've ever seen.
I'll have your badge for this. I'm in the fucking FBI!
Oh, yeah, what that stand for? Fucking Big Idiot?
PHILLIPS: If this shit gets crazy, I'm gonna go crazy shit!
God, are you all right?
I ruptured my hymen!
This, pure extasy.
I'm not doing this!
Do it.
Oh, sorry about your dead human friend, Phillips.
That is good shit!
Well, fuck me!
Maybe!
Is Phil in?
He's servicing a client.
Is that what I think it is?
PHILLIPS: Here I go, here I go, here I go.
I'm light-headed, I'm light-headed!
Oh, my!